qu'est-ce que tu préfères avoir devant
toi moi
ou l'idée que ça pourrait être un lapin
oh tu es plus jolie que le lapin
tu es beaucoup plus jolie que le lapin
je t'aurai
comment as-tu fait pour regarder dans le très
bon endroit d'un aspirateur
où le lapin pourrait être
euh
j'ai appris à halluciner
ma fille rosa qui avait trois ans quand
j'apprenais à le faire
elle a tous ces amis invisibles
et
elle m'a appris à voir des amis invisibles
mais après six mois à
faire cette conjuration  ces
hallucinations pendant
environ 16 heures par jour j'ai perdu le contrôle
et je n'ai jamais vu de lapins sortir du
mur
tu sais maintenant iras-tu toujours voir un
dessin animé
plus souvent depuis le tournage
de roger rabbit je ne rêverais pas de
manger un lapin non certainement pas
mais dis moi bob comment es tu devenu
acteur euh
un ami à moi
allait auditionner pour euh une pièce amateur
et je suis allé avec lui
au  jouer et nous étions dans le bar et
je prenais un verre et
le gars est venu et a dit tu es le
prochain
oh d'accord et je suis monté et j'ai
auditionné
et j'ai eu le rôle principal dans la pièce
et la première nuit, un agent est venu le voir
et a dit que tu devrais faire  c'est
professionnel alors
dites d'accord, trouvez-moi un emploi et je le ferai
et c'est tout, je n'ai jamais été sans
travail depuis comment avez-vous appris à jouer euh en
étudiant des femmes
comme les femmes
ont dû garder la bouche fermée
pendant des milliers d'années
et euh
donc ils  ont développé un autre langage
ils ont développé le langage d'
expression qu'ils expriment il n'y a rien de
plus dramatique
qu'une femme
et le
drame concerne des moments privés
et une femme peut exprimer un moment privé d'un
simple mouvement de sourcil
beaucoup plus facilement qu'un homme peut
alors c'est comme ça que j'ai commencé tu as réalisé
ton premier film rude ironie sur une
tribu gitane pendant la guerre tu as
une minute pour me mettre là
juste
l'histoire commence au milieu d'une guerre
qui dure depuis trop longtemps tous les
déserteurs sont anéantis  une  ypersonne vue
avec un déserteur est anéantie un jeune
déserteur quitte le camp qu'il dirige il
rejoint une tribu de gitans déguisés en
femme les gitans pensent qu'il a des
pouvoirs magiques il fait l'amour avec une des
gitanes il tombe amoureux
ils ont cette romance  pendant qu'il est
habillé en femme et qu'elle est de toute façon une femme
et finalement
cela mène à une tragédie totale et
ensuite
il reste la guerre
tue tout le monde finalement ce qui est pire
diriger
ou travailler avec un lapin jouer avec un
lapin
c'est pire vous obtenez des choses qui sortent
du  mur
alors aimerez-vous cagney laughton brando
et peter laurie ne réalisent qu'un seul film dans
votre vie
euh
non
probablement pas
peut-être mais non
tout le monde se souvient du sexe et de la drogue et du
rock and roll et frappez-moi avec votre
bâton rythmique en endurant qui est dans votre
film où est-il  maintenant
ivre je devrais penser ouais quelque part il
a eu il a eu beaucoup de problèmes en
allemagne il a été expulsé d'allemagne et
euh j'ai perdu sa trace après ça je continue de
recevoir
un appel fou  de lui au milieu de
la nuit disant que tout
va bien tickata et vous obtenez ceci à
trois heures du matin vous savez
voyons-le je ne sais pas où
il est il se tourne quelque part
que répondez-vous à la  les gens qui disent que
tu es une personne naïve baise-les
bleu